hey my whoa haha how's it going brother
Anees FIFA best intro ever
I'm so sorry that was disgusting welcome
to d4 dark dreams don't die as a game
might by the people who made deadly
premonition I think I'm just guessing I
yeah you know what that's probably true
uh this game is described as being
incredibly weird
I'm incredibly weird it's supposed to
have an interesting story I love an
interesting story you bros love an
interesting story and first actually you
know what I really want to say that
thank you I guess
we recently played Kathryn and there was
so much amazing support for me playing
that game which is understandable it's
an amazing game but it really reminded
me of mine outside so corny
it really reminded me over how much I
love doing YouTube because the
excitement that I get from you bros my
fans over me playing a game and I really
feel like we're playing the game
together is the reason why I fell in
love with this YouTube thing in the
first place and I've been doing a lot of
one-off type of games for a long time
and I feel like it's it's time for me to
get back into doing more series of games
the problem is that it's really hard to
find games that are good there's no way
I will know if the games are good I
won't know if I like it I won't know if
you bros like it and there's a weird
niche and mix-and-match there but uh oh
[ __ ] I almost put the game but I did
some research I looked through a lot of
different games and this one was by far
the one that I felt like I could be a
really good series so I'm gonna turn
down the Lightning a little bit and
we're gonna play it I think there's
gonna be a lot of fun um hey maybe works
out maybe it doesn't but at least we're
trying I'm trying for you bros here so I
don't know hopefully that's that's worth
something we'll see
really interesting menu screen by the
way the audio i kept the game running in
the background for such a long time and
it's so beautiful
my name's why am I so emotional and so
nice you sell off the backup music I
don't know it's really like a lot of
title screens are just [ __ ] annoying
this is a work of fiction any similarity
to actual persons places organizations
etc is purely coincidental
we both know that's not the case
come on game what are you all here it is
again gorgeous this is a story of a man
with a very strange fate okay I already
love this game
god oh no no no it was so beautiful I
must be on my period or something I'm
like this really dark prologue the day
okay I know I'll chill I'm sorry today
it all began
I'm gonna guess my wife just got shot
that's now staring into the eyes of an
owl so this game came out on xbox one
first as an exclusive but we've all know
that if a game comes out is an exclusive
Amex oh that's pretty dope on Xbox one
it doesn't mean [ __ ] it's still gonna
come out on PC and PlayStation
eventually playstation they'll commit to
their exclusive let's sorry I put a
little personal console agenda in there
oh yeah it's definitely their creative
Deadly Premonition look at the
awkwardness in the animation it's
[ __ ] amazing it's turning me on
it's probably not appropriate develop by
axis games
yep I guess that [ __ ] so the hand that
you see here is supposed to be like the
Kinect and I hope it will still be a
thrilling experience regardless if I'm
playing on the PC investigate the clues
okay well let's look at this on a boy
cameron lake as a doll okay
alright grab the credit medal did it
this is really weird
I don't know what I'm doing push to sign
by right click okay I did it
cool I grabbed all the credit medals how
do I move left and right okay with left
and right arrow key
okay we did it
it's a ASD
oh okay works with AC turn around and
observe the standing leg sign move there
to the side of the screen then used to
change direction okay
I'll be grabbing all of these now and
I'll be pushing this ball for no reason
with my connecting to powers get it
connect I think that was a joke it's
pretty good
daddy he's looking at me seems worried
oh my god how was I supposed to read all
that okay Sam I daddy-san Danny sat he
has nice gloves wonder where you bought
this what do I keep standing like this
so anime [ __ ] long [ __ ] love anime
I'm such a weeaboo move closer to the
owl okay how do select the button and
then move by clicking I really feel like
Japanese games are coming back man and
we're kind of in a rut for a while in
one thing maybe maybe that's just me I
don't know whenever this is a Japanese
game I always feel more excited
push push the out why would I push it
out or al ly [ __ ] that Ali's [ __ ]
huge I don't want to [ __ ] with a now
like that [ __ ] am i doing oh my god it's
so cute
oh my god I love the theme then dan
Denton Denton Denton oh [ __ ] my braids
are you inside my scarf that's that's a
stupid daddy saw everyone knows if
you're on a leg you're supposed to crawl
that's obvious
oh god please she can't die she's like
I'm about that I have a French I deserve
today I'm so sorry if you have a French
that was a joke
I was underserved darks dreams don't die
so anyway yes
of course we needed an intro with the
music that's - is that a bubble like a
bubble
okay so that's the main character we
have green blue eyes and a little smudge
such as me what is my fault
that it feel a little bit what is this
okay all right
wow that looked like it [ __ ] hurt if
you Bruce know what's going on feel free
to tell me at any point um would love to
know
he looks pretty dead yeah no he's
definitely dead
trying to smudge no he's alive
strawberry flavor well that's good to
know that's my favorite and we haven't
see you again this time either
okay well hopefully this will make sense
later there once we have a heavy rain
little of eggy doesn't it
[ __ ] love heavy rain just one of my
favorite games little Peggy okay my scar
aches I have an old scar okay alright my
name is David yo okay Foreman up with
the Boston PD former knock okay and now
a detective who searches the past
within our cordless 100% agave tequila
my dislikes and mainly drugs and Julia
my chewing gum then two years ago uh-huh
someone killed my wife oh no see I guess
I'm using every second of my life to
solve the case
using a certain very special power ooh
this is interesting it must be a wolf
among us as well isn't it the character
the main character at least all right so
our job now is to get out of the
bathroom we have a broker minute
reminded of that day Oh what about the
toilet follow the arrow and move it down
I can do that
no I apparently I can't do that epilim
okay why can't we sit on a twit up let's
do some thinking an expression of
emotion yes the person who sent once the
feelings to be understood sometimes
however those feelings remain in a
slightly different form oh my god this
is so serious guy can't forgotten
treasures mementos I can't help but
laughing okay we could collected a
memento which is of probably our dead
wife I still had a worn by librarian pbl
BPL perhaps it was a gift from a lover
it has a name
Dominic Dean a mild librarian by the day
okay the way maybe the sender of this
shoe was one of her victims either way a
but she wasn't d this memento has lost
it power what does that even mean that's
so strange life is strange all right
we're moving over here we are already
investigated a toilet what do we got
here a bathtub that became from little
Peggy
oh of course yeah I know she was there I
totally saw her
how did I'm it I need me
Kauai here I out know everyone has their
own place to work I think a small desk
in an office
molten-hot factory quiet library the
register supermarket or in the middle of
an intersection [ __ ] love his Lisp
golf balls a kitchen for some it's the
whole town what the [ __ ] you can't just
pull the [ __ ] desert eagle on me
please don't
okay well go ahead then [ __ ] oh don't
play with my emotion died this has been
my place to work this game just [ __ ]
reeks of charisma
I [ __ ] love a and a world full of
triple-a soulless titles we have games
like this this case isn't clear okay
well let's go out and investigate the
game clearly tells me to go to the door
so I guess I'll just do that but we
could just look around a little bit just
for fun sake just for funsies is that
Peggy did you hear about David's wife
bit out of focus - I heard it was
revenge for one of his investigations
sure sounds like the way they operate
sending a deadly message
we've been drinking a lot I guess we'll
decide to kill it how will I drink
without a memo never mind
so what are these points mixing there's
only one thing I need after work to keep
straighter nothing mixed in why would
you mix with tequila
[ __ ] so I'll drag it to my mouth game
play right there pull it down yeah ha ha
ha ha badass the perfect stimulation the
perfect rate up and she pierced when
we're drunk
I guess since we use he doesn't look
happy at all but the [ __ ] are you on
about
cranberry juice well Peggy loved it oh
she used to blow bubbles mothers
soundtrack it's [ __ ] amazing tequila
tastes like Shay I'm just kidding
if there's any shot at EdTech it's
probably tequila I don't know why
because you do the lemon in the salt
part after it's always fun I don't know
or you're not a [ __ ] like the main
character and you don't shake it shake
it shake it shake it shake it shake it
shake it like a Polaroid picture we're
doing another shot ok well it's not as
bad as its last time but he'll I'll take
it thank you how do i I want to go back
she'll grab that a letter from little
Peggy I got an achievement you can't see
it though
David the thought of reading this makes
me very happy
of you're reading this I hope you've
calmed down a little I love you as you
are and I love the David you become this
is second time I've written that do you
remember the first time today I find all
my old letters it's strange they become
your case materials this is weird all
the letters I ever sent a perfect
collection going back to high school
days you're obviously important they're
obviously important to you stored so
neatly
maybe you respect them too much to tear
them open is that it so this is a
challenge from Peggy I am now that Peggy
I'm sorry I'm reading so badly and to
the David you'll become I've hidden my
letters all Denis I want you to find all
of me and all of our memories and no the
Peggy I was the Peggy I am now in the
Peggy I'll become little Peggy on
September 14 2009 ok
beautiful I enjoy that note I usually
don't like notes I wonder why just feel
like notes are always so poorly written
but that's probably just because I play
I know I'm mature each games no offense
doing all the games I play okay here we
go
um go to the kitchen and examine the cup
board this is so much better than
playing at Kinect I'm so [ __ ] glad
I'm not playing it at the Kinect no
friends why do I keep saying that I
don't know this is not the kind of game
we want to play on the Kinect
do you boys remember I used to play
deadly Dead Rising it's called that way
IRA Deadly Premonition Dan rising was a
Kinect game that was actually not bad
but it was just so [ __ ] annoying to
play on the Kinect that I was just like
I don't want to keep playing this even
though I enjoy the game I'm just not
gonna keep playing it because the Kinect
is just [ __ ] annoying am i eating a
fortune cookie
no I'm smashing up common sense may not
be the world common sense values are
never the same this is our read notes
apparently alright that's great
scribe with some coffee so it's good to
restore after a tequila make you tired
as [ __ ] afterwards okay I really [ __ ]
love coffee apparently jesus [ __ ]
christ it says two out of three fortune
cookies so I'll I'll smash another one
just for good ol sakes brofist yeah life
is love you heard it here first bros
feel free to put that on my gravestone
please do okay I can drink coffee two
more times and I can eat a fortune
cookie
two more times but life is too short I
would say okay what have we got over
here we can okay so this is art we
should probably look at this well they
are oh alright what do we get no active
cases available
okay well I'm sure this will get updated
eventually I think it's time for us to
get out of here
um I'm glad the game action players are
doing know what am i doing I don't I
don't know what what am i doing you tell
me uh well okay I think I missed
something I pushed a lamp is that what
you wanted
oh yes let's put some background music
that'll be nice
what do you boys want to play a string
No
okay you know what that'd be nice yes
none of that I want string I want this
one no this one confirm what is this one
I like this beautiful gorgeous discovery
what is this a magazine why are we
looking inside a magazine I have no idea
we find a new item the working of the
brain neurons and synapses the brain is
formed from complex neural network ok
I'll just read this
maybe it's interesting or like useful
the network is created from specialized
cells called neurons each working as a
functioning unit these neurons carry
electrical and chemical signals when a
signal is transmitted inside a single
neuron they are exchanged in the form of
electrical pulses
however when signals are passed between
different neurons they are exchanged in
the chemical form by a neurotransmitters
the part containing the neurotransmitter
is called synapse if anything goes wrong
with this part neurons will and be
unable to correct correctly pass
information between neurons this can
lead to a variety of illness or amnesia
right problems with synapses can be both
cognitive and acquired due to injury and
may be induced temporarily or
chronically by taking specific drugs so
what the game is telling us is that the
main character used to be a drug addict
and it's telling us the consequences on
just that in a discovery book that's
pretty clever
that looks like a fish for a second no
no I wanted to grab it
do we need to grab all of them maybe to
progress like a beer or like a little
squirrel
attracted to my potato chips a cute
squirrel sorry I forgot to add that
little detail what is this vision thing
go to the kitchen and examine the file
ok so that's my objective my apologies
bros I didn't know that she's just
again let's go inside the kitchen what's
the objective the file where's the file
ooh this could be how I need to clear
this case for now I need to go outside
any time after that okay so now I
understand my bad breasts well at least
we're learning a little bit about the
game and all the stuff but we won't grab
the phone for now I want to grab the
case I don't know how I missed that
eliminated suspects okay what do we got
man I can't imagine seeing someone you
love dead like that at that day when I
came to I was already lying in the ICU
the only thing I do remember other words
that little Peggy was better she died
poor little Peggy look for Dean is that
what almost no blood
who is the whose words keep spinning in
my head
interesting
this is getting interesting
traces fingerprints at the time uh-huh
no compelling evidence the case hit a
dead end okay I quit the BPD however
under the right circumstances I now have
the capability to solve even a dead in
case oh yeah because we have some sort
of super power right what is this
okay that's the shoe that we had right
yeah it is
ah ha ha ha ha I'll do everything in my
power to find this deep and when I do Oh
Peggy Oh someone's at the door
ok Bres you know what I'm gonna have to
end this first episode there if you want
to see more go ahead and leave a like
I'll probably play more regardless
because I [ __ ] love this and this is
amazing and I want to play more but
that's it for now they were so much for
watching and as always stay awesome
press I know you will